[Music]
I'm Darren George and I grow and restore
bonsai trees I'm going to walk you
through how I restore an overgrown
bonsai tree the tree that I'm working on
today is called cotoniasta this
particular tree was started by a bonsai
professional up north in England and
came into my possession when the
previous owner decided to give up Bonsai
and had let the tree deteriorate
somewhat the tree has fallen into
disrepair it has several overgrown
branches and there are also a number of
branches that have completely died the
dead wood is rotting and falling away
from the tree
foreign
the first step in restoring this bonsai
tree is going to be cleaning out the
massive branches so that I can see the
underlying structure of the tree I'm
going to remove any dead pieces and
generally thin out the massive leaves
and twigs
now I can see what's going on inside of
the canopy I can see that there are a
couple of branches that are growing from
the same position they're crowding each
other out and making the tree look quite
messy and spoiling the flow of the
design so I'm going to select one or two
branches to completely remove to open up
some space to ensure the health of the
branches that remain and also create a
more open and rounded feel to the canopy
where I am removing a larger Branch I'm
going to use a special putty that we
call cut paste the cut paste helps the
wound heal much faster than it
ordinarily would and prevents rot and
bacteria setting in
where I've created some space in the
canopy I'm going to use some wire to
reposition a couple of the remaining
branches so that we've got quite a nice
even distribution of foliage around the
tree and remove any large gaps in the
canopy and once they're all in position
the work for this moment is complete and
I can allow the tree to respond and grow
into the new shape
several months later in the spring and
the state of the Deadwood is really
starting to bother me the longer I leave
it the more it's going to deteriorate so
I'd like to get the dead wood treated
and hardened before I apply the
treatment to the dead wood I have to
ensure that the dead wood is Thoroughly
dry I keep it out of the elements under
shelter so that it can dry out I'm using
a two-part epoxy resin it has a solvent
mixed in with it that encourages the
resin to penetrate the soft dead wood so
that the epoxy can Harden further into
the core of the wood and hopefully allow
it to last longer
I'm applying the epoxy resin to the dead
wood as carefully as I can trying to
ensure not to get it on the live wood or
on the soil
I'm going to let it dry for a couple of
days
now that epoxy is completely dry I'm
rigorously brushing it to take the sheen
off the surface of the wood I really
want it to look old and Sun bleached
rather than shiny and new so using a
steel brush it roughs up the surface and
takes that reflection off the wood
foreign
[Music]
this tree has absolutely exploded with
growth the branches are super long super
thick and really really healthy once
again I need to come along I need to cut
back these branches to regain the shape
of the canopy I'm also checking for any
opportunities to reposition any branches
that aren't in the ideal locations
so with all these really long shoots
that have grown over summer I'm going to
trim them back to regain the silhouette
and it also gives me another opportunity
to apply some wire to reposition any new
branches that have developed since and
continue filling in the tree's crown
now with all the watering that I've been
doing over the hot summer we've got some
hard water stains built up around the
base of the tree on the bottom of the
trunk and on some of the roots on the
soil surface
I'm using a toothbrush and vinegar to
try and dissolve and scrub off some of
that white calcium buildup
on the summer surface there are some
undissolved fertilizer pellets I'll
quickly brush those off to reveal the
green moss underneath
and that concludes the work on this tree
now I'm done with this Bonsai I'm really
excited to see how it responds and
continue working with it as it grows
into the future
foreign